foreign
mogler I'm a
a I call myself a senior partner meeting
the senior generation of our family
business because I'm fourth generation
my children Fifth and their children who
are already uh growing up uh in Rural
America on the farm are sixth generation
um offspring of uh of a great
grandfather of mine who uh put his
stakes in the ground here back in the
late 1800s my father thought it would be
strategically wise to diversify Beyond
just cattle and so that's when we got
into a modern pork production and so our
family's been involved in modern pork
production
the reason that we have the strongest
economy in the world is because we have
the most affordable food supply and we
have the infrastructure to get it to
people in a in a low-cost way that it
can be safe and affordable and therefore
we can have um you know a lot of people
don't have to worry about raising food
for their families but as a result of
that become more and more Generations
removed from our farming or our
agricultural Roots people have really
lost an understanding of of really how
true Farms work today
proposition 12
it really had a lot of very troubling
details not science based whatsoever to
make it very restrictive on us to
implement and practice the husbandry
practices that we have implemented on
our farms and so they put very specific
space requirements 24 square feet for a
gestating
um sow so a solid would be the term for
a female pig that you know would be
carrying young it would be pregnant and
not only that but during her lifetime
for the age of five months and Beyond
she always has given that amount of
space and she can never be housed what
we call individual maternity pens or
what is referred to as stalls where
they're housed by themselves and the
reason we do that is to protect
themselves from themselves
so very troubling to us that somebody
else would impose standards when who
knows best other than those of us who
for multiple Generations you know skills
I mean really the only way you learn
that is to live it and those who live it
know best
we chose as an industry to hopefully use
legal processes through the courts and
it was appealed all the way to the
Supreme Court of the United States which
is a huge Victory
unfortunately it was a 5-4 vote so it
had it been four to five this law would
have been nullified would not be
implemented but because uh the the the
appeal failed it will become codified
into law as it stands now July 1st
the farm we built in 2015 doesn't meet
prop 12 standards and so the farm we
built in 2014 had the individual
maternity pins
we knew that it wasn't a matter of if it
would be when we would convert that farm
to a group housing standard that would
meet a market in the U.S and so we
actually had the great opportunity to
convert a farm that we intended to
convert to prop 12 standards that farm
in 2014 cost us 12 million dollars this
partnership to build this
5200 style farm that produces 155
000 pigs a year
in 2022 which was last year we spent an
additional
8.7 million dollars so nearly 70 percent
of the original construction costs to
make it prop 12 compliant we had to add
a whole nother Barn to create 24 square
feet we had to remove all the individual
maternity pins and replace them with not
only pins but pens that have electronic
South feeding stations we typically on
that farm prior to conversion
95 to 96 of the animals that are
inseminated would be a successful
conception they call that conception
rate so 96 percent of all females that
are mated achieve pregnancy a phenomenal
performance metric
we slipped to 70 percent
we've done our part
but not every Farm has been able to do
that it takes a certain amount of
business Acumen it takes a certain
amount of intestinal fortitude it takes
a certain amount of just long-term
commitment to the legacy of farming in
order to make those types of commitments
and at some point in time your appetite
for debt
your ability and appetite for risk your
lender's appetite for risk reaches a
point
where you go no further and then you're
forced with the decision of
basically going out of business
or shutting the farm down
and selling it
and so a lot of businesses pork
producers like myself are going through
a very very high level of financial
stress today in spite of
the Supreme Court ruling and so the
timing really could not have been worse
the financial stress is real
the uncertainty is real
so this is a very serious situation for
a lot of families today